what's going on guys this is Robin we
are here with the conclusion of Batman
and Superman fighting the anti-superman
and God the ending to this is absolutely
dope okay so what this does picking up
off the last video that we did which
I'll have is a pinned link down in the
comment section that what we have here
is David basically being taught how to
be a superhero alongside Batman right
now remember David is from an alternate
reality so he's not really used to how
things work when it comes to stuff on
earth now one of the things that happens
here is Batman in teaching David to be a
hero actually has him face off against a
villain like rat catcher now the reason
why Batman does that is because rat
catcher doesn't really matter but it's
not as though he kind of throw him in to
the deep end with like Two-Face or the
Riddler or anybody like that but one of
the things that Batman communicates with
David is that if he's going to be a
superhero on this Earth and he's going
to operate on a broad level he's gonna
have to come to the understanding some
places on Earth are darker than others
and Gotham City is the darkest like
Gotham City is not a place you move to
on purpose you know what I mean like you
end up there like you're traveling
through there your car breaks down down
somehow you run out of money and now
you're stuck like that's how you end up
in Gotham City and so what we end up
doing here is transitioning over to the
Joker and the key now here's the thing
one of the things you guys pointed out
in the comments section I probably
should have mentioned this in the last
video the key as he exists here is a
reworked version of a very old character
in DC Comics that his powers are starkly
different or at least different enough
that they can call him a new character
that he basically has the ability to
kind of access virtually anywhere in
existence and one of the cool things
about this story is that we're actually
going to focus on how DC is changing
things up with the Multiverse which is
cool and so what we end up finding out
is the Joker arrives here on the scene
with basically the angler of a guy
called Engelman now angle man is kind of
an interesting character he's not overly
important in DC Comics but the device
that he has which is more often than not
referred to as the angler has the
ability to kind of relocate Things based
on the user's wishes and it's also got
other powers as well but what matters in
the confines of this story is that it
allows them to achieve a measure of
teleportation they because what ends up
happening is that in the middle of David
working alongside Superman and the Flash
and so on is you suddenly have just this
massive flood that engulfs the city of
Gotham out of nowhere and the reason why
this happens is because of the fact that
what the key and the Joker had done is
in the city of Gotham the hip literally
deposited using the powers of the angler
this giant doorway and then in turn
using the ability of the key to open
that doorway to basically anywhere he
wants it to be the doorway opens to
Gotham Harbor which basically just
floods the entirety of Gotham City now
of course this requires Batman Superman
David and all those guys to respond only
for us to find out it's the distraction
the reason why this all matters is
because while the entire doorway and
everything is wrapped up pretty quickly
that Batman and David have a moment
together when Batman basically tells
David he can't drive the Batmobile but
in a moment of distraction The Joker and
the key yanked David threw a doorway
that the key created and now David is in
the clutches of the Joker and here's
what's so nuts about this right like as
you guys know when it comes to the Joker
are in Sidekicks killing Sidekicks has
kind of been his thing now in the
comments people were like no that's not
the Joker's main Emma but it kind of has
been ever since like the death of Jason
Todd specifically with regards to Batman
there's always the ongoing fear that if
Joker gets his hands on one of Batman's
Sidekicks that the Joker will kill him
that's the concern here because the
first thing the Joker wants from David
is he wants to know the identities of
Batman and Superman now what's kind of
funny about this is explicitly in this
story Batman told Superman we're not
giving David our secret identities we
don't know him well enough yet we don't
know him well enough to give him that
information because any number of things
could happen so the reality is that
Jokers demanding information from David
that David doesn't readily have but in
an effort to kind of coax them along the
Joker exposes David to the Joker toxin
now here's the thing David's never
encountered The Joker toxin before and
he's never experienced it but for those
of you guys who are familiar with DC
Comics as you know there's varying
degrees of the Joker toxin sometimes the
toxin will kill you other times it'll
just make you temporarily insane it just
depends on what being told in the story
and what the Joker's own motivations are
but David having never experienced this
before quite literally has a kind of
psychotic break right starts losing his
mind and freaking out over the fact that
everything he sees is basically just
Joker and so of course while David's
being held hostage you basically have
Superman and Batman and the Teen Titans
and those guys all hunting for David
himself what's so ironic about this and
this is something that's exceedingly
important here is Superman's reaction to
this because as Batman is talking to
Robin what he tells him is he says that
Superman is incredibly angry at the
Joker but he's more angry at himself for
basically putting David in the Joker's
crosshairs putting David out there as a
superhero and it was only a matter of
time before something like this happened
and so that's a very important thing and
I want you to keep that in the back of
your head as we get closer to the end of
this video and so one of the things that
happens is Batman kind of going through
all these different buildings that are
most likely being used by The Joker and
the key but finding virtually nothing
ends up discovering a single device out
there with a serial number was not
completely filed off by the key and that
by using this information alongside just
this detective work right Batman's just
you know the power of the plot Batman
ultimately deduces exactly where they're
operating out of and so alongside
Superman and the rest of the Teen Titans
they arrive at the headquarters of the
key and the Joker only to enter through
the doorway and then find a giant
expanse of doors and there's no telling
where these lead to and in fact that's
what makes this moment so cool is
because if they were to open one door
they could just be sucked into the
vacuum of space and they would all die
except for Superman if they were sucked
through another door they could end up
in the bottom of the ocean they could
open a door and they could end up in 65
million years in the past there's no way
to know what would happen here and it's
one of the coolest things now what DC is
also going to do and one of the most fun
ways ever is they're gonna give us the
most comic book logic thing that I think
I've ever seen and it's going to be
absolutely amazing but jumping back over
to David being held by the Joker and the
key we get this really amazing moment
and this is one of the most important
certain things to understand about
what's happening here right so when
David is talking to the key what he says
or at least what the key says is that
David passed out after being beat over
the head with a crowbar by The Joker
that's the Joker's Mo when it comes to
Sidekicks he basically beat Jason Todd
nearly to death and then blew him up so
it's kind of been a thing with him and
crowbars and Sidekicks ever since but
what the key says is that in his younger
years he grew up in this exceedingly
small town but he felt frustrated by how
limited the minds were of not just
himself but everybody around him so what
he started doing was experimenting with
psychotropic drugs in order to quote
unquote unlock the 90 of the human brain
that has potential right because the old
wives tale is we only ever use 10 of our
brain now of course DC is not really
going with the old wives tale version
and in fact even the key himself says
that's Malarkey that's nonsense right at
any given time over the course of a day
we're using the entirety of our brain in
some capacity right it's not as though
90 is laying dormant and if we can tap
into that 90 we can develop telepathy
and telekinesis and we can all to
reality and so on and so forth and so
what he did is by experimenting with
these psychotropic drugs he actually
started breaking free of the limitations
of the human brain being able to
experience and to understand things in a
way that a human being simply just
normally can't do is he's basically
hyper evolved his brain that's really
all he did but the kicker to this is
that his brain is always hungering for
information now what he says and really
when David asks a question why are you
outlying yourself with the joker what
the key says is that he's basically
working with the joker because the
Jokers agreed to provide him with some
of his experimental psychotropic drugs
now the real question you have to ask
here is why would you buy drugs from The
Joker and why would you take drugs from
The Joker because I promise you my
friend that's a high you are never gonna
come down from it'll be bad it'll be
very very bad but the bigger reason why
is because it allows the key to
experiment and sort of see how he feels
about all this stuff now I do want to
say this as a disclaimer you should
never do any of that stuff right never
mess with that kind of stuff I feel like
that needs to be said because I know we
have some younger people who do watch
the YouTube channel having said said
that what David says in an attempt to
beg for his life is he reveals to the
key that he's not even from this
universe that he's from an alternate
reality and arrived here on a spaceship
now this is huge this is the single
biggest moment to come out of this comic
outside of the ending of this comic and
here's the reason why what the key
realizes is that with David coming from
an alternate reality if you were to
imagine the Multiverse being a
collection of houses on a block all the
key needs is a key to the front door of
his house and many can access any house
he wants to the Multiverse becomes his
playground and so by David having a ship
and having the means by which the key
can leave the universe he in turn can do
whatever he wants to with the Multiverse
he can jump in and out of any Universe
using the ship he'll always remember and
he'll always be able to get back the
super comic book logic that I was
talking about right that moment comes
along when Batman and Superman and these
guys are investigating all these doors
and then Batman and Superman both come
to the realization that the Joker wears
gloves but the key does not so super
Superman using his his Superman powers
all right Superman becomes Batman but he
uses like his super Superman powers and
then sees like a fingerprint on a door
handle and that's when he realizes
that's the door they went through it's
the most McGuffin thing ever right it is
the most just convenient plot thing ever
but it is fun right this is one of the
most fun stories that I think I've read
in a long long time so honestly I don't
really mind but of course once they get
into the room the Joker's in the midst
of just beating David with a crowbar and
that's when Superman says step away from
him now what follows is one of the
coolest moments this is what I'm talking
this is what I'm talking about guys this
is when things get cool so immediately
in response to Batman Superman the Teen
Titans and all these guys the key opens
a door which just leads to this giant
monster coming in and then the Joker
makes his Escape David despite being
worn by everybody else immediately goes
after the Joker and he manages to track
him down and some gigantic crazy looking
fun house now the reality of this is
that David is not buying anything he
sees and he doesn't really care instead
he immediately goes after the Joker and
he manages to overpower him but in this
moment of extreme anger he says you
tortured me you tortured me and you got
off on it if I lay eyes on you ever
again I swear I will kill you I don't
care if it's tomorrow or 20 years from
now I will kill you and this is when we
get the Revelation this is the origin
story from Magog and DC Comics
man the anti-superman if there ever was
one dude I love the character of magoc
it's so amazing because that's what this
is right as you guys know Magog killed
the Joker like it's what set everything
off with his character right it's just
it's one of the coolest moments ever
right now we'll talk about him here in a
second all right we'll talk about him
here in a little bit because I know
people who are not familiar with DC are
like who the hell is Magog like when the
world's going on with Magog no he is
dude Magog is dope like he's absolutely
one of the coolest characters out there
you guys remember that story where he
absolutely dominated Superman and it
wasn't even close like it wasn't even
close son it was was a man man I'm sorry
I'm so excited people so what this does
here of course is it picks up with David
having not killed the Joker but the Teen
Titans basically chastising him because
they had to pull David off the Joker he
was going to kill him right he was going
to kill this guy and that's when like
literally David has to come to accept
this fact that he can't just kill he has
to be able to control his anger but even
Batman sits down with Superman and says
look I understand where you're coming
from you see David as not really even a
sidekick but more like somebody under
your wing you're his mentor I would even
go so far as to argue that it
borderlines a kind of sun type situation
but the reality here is nothing is
curbing David's rage he struggles with
anger in a way that we simply just can't
understand now the reason behind this
and the reason why it all matters so
much is because in a lot of ways David
sees himself as the reason for why his
family died in the first place remember
in the last video that we did we never
quite learned the full origin story of
David but one of the things that we
found out here is that David being on
this ship and arriving on Earth they
were designed to be vessels they're
originally two of them and they were
designed to be vessels that would
basically explore the Multiverse they
would chart the Multiverse not that
dissimilar from what the Fantastic Four
do in Marvel Comics the problem with
this is that David messing around with
one of the ships ends up inadvertently
blowing the ship up and so when the time
comes when like his world is basically
ending his parents have to send him away
on the one ship that's available because
it can only house one person and David
sent away knowing that had he not messed
with the second ship in the first place
his parents would be traveling alongside
him as well so he sees his actions as
the reason for why they died that and
the fact that over the course of his
life there were a moments when he could
have stepped in to help people but fear
got the better of him and he ran away
leading to other people dying so again
it's one of these things where he sees
himself wanting to be a superhero but
nothing he's done over the course of his
life has given him the impression that
he's capable of doing it now the reality
here and you know this and I know this
and it's one of the things that just you
learn to deal with over the course of
your life everybody makes mistakes
everybody screws up and nobody gets
things perfect but David hasn't quite
figured that out yet and so he carries a
lot of guilt here the problem is the
potential actions of David's rage
getting the better of him would lead to
the death of anybody else who's out
there and right wrong or otherwise the
role of superheroes are to really be
more humanitarian peacekeepers than to
be like a police force right the police
force is Earth three which we will cover
because that story is dope but the thing
about this is that Superman ultimately
ends up taking David and putting him
inside of a device in the Fortress of
Solitude that will basically expose him
to the Red Sun radiation and basically
neutralizes Powers but before he's able
to pull the lever Superman removes him
right and he says look I'm not gonna
take your powers away I can do better
right I can be better now again a lot of
why Superman is doing things that he
wouldn't normally do because under any
normal circumstance he would have been
like yeah man sorry about your luck
David he would have pulled that lever
and be like I'll see you on the other
side home slice and that would be it
right but the reason why he's not doing
that is because again he sees himself
reflected in David because their origin
stories are almost identical right sent
away from a Dying World their biological
parents are dead they arrive on a
foreign planet that they don't know
anything about their powers start
manifesting they don't really know how
they work that when they arrive here
there really isn't any true moral
compass they kind of have to learn from
the Local Natives on how things work in
the world that they're in there's a lot
of similarities between these two
characters but if Superman and David are
talking to each other there's like a
giant noise from Down Below in the
forces of solitude only to find out the
key and the Joker have arrived and
basically unlocked all these different
animals now the question you'd be asking
yourself is how did the key and Joker
find the Fortress of Solitude of
Superman because it's the Fortress of
Solitude it's not easily found right
like what we end up doing is jumping
back to about 30 minutes before David
was rescued by Batman and Superman when
he was being interrogated by the key and
what the key had done in talking to
David is that by exposing David to his
own psychotropic drugs in turn he forced
David to dump all the secrets all the
information that he has everything he
knows about Batman everything he knows
about Superman his origin story his
Homeworld how the Multiverse works or at
least what limited knowledge he does
have how his ship Works how to turn it
on the whole nine yards right in a
matter of minutes the key got way more
out of David than the Joker ever could
have and so as a distraction what the
key ends up doing is releasing a whole
bunch of different villains that have
all in some form or fashion appeared in
DC Comics over the years they're not
overly important I always thought that
Ferlin nixely is one of the coolest
villains out there he's he was literally
the son at least I want to say he was
the son of the landlady of Clark Kent
but maybe that was before the new 52. I
don't remember off top my head but the
thing about this is that with with the
key basically getting his hands on
Superman he opens the doorway which
teleports Superman into the very chamber
that's designed to shut down his powers
and so while the Red Sun radiation does
not destroy Superman's powers it does
bring them down enough to where he's
basically the version of Superman that
he was in the new 52 when his powers
were reduced and he was riding around in
like the black Superman shirt on the
motorcycle but of course the key using
the distraction makes his way over to
the ship of Dave of it and then intends
to turn it on but when David Goes to
make a move to defeat the key the key
simply says freeze and that's when we
end up finding out that in the moment
when he was messing with David's head
using psychotropic drugs and learning
everything that David had to say the key
instilled is kind of subtle command in
the mind of David that when the word
freeze was stated David wouldn't be able
to move and so In This Moment the key
pulls out what he calls the master key
right this gun that basically breaks
down matter on the molecular level
points it to David but then Batman
arrives just in time to save the life of
David and the keys ultimately defeated
now again one of the things about this
is that for a moment David's anger
almost gets the better of him and he
almost kills key but in turn he stands
down right and he says I'm not going to
do that right I am not that person
Batman and Superman have taught me to be
a better hero I'm not going to destroy
you but the end is coming folks the end
is coming and let me tell you man it is
dope because what happens here right
what happens here is that the key had
already activated the ship of David and
when that happened David starts phasing
right literally start starts phasing out
of the entirety of the universe and even
when he asked Batman and Superman like
is there anything you can do to help me
the response is there's nothing we can
do like there's literally nothing that
we can do here we don't know how to
deactivate your ship or anything like
that and what is up going on is David as
he phases ultimately disappears and when
he's gone he reappears on an alternate
World met by a guy named Gog this my
friends is the origin story of how David
became the Magog in DC Comics now if you
want to know more about Magog make sure
you check the link in the comments
section because that will send you to a
story called Kingdom Come and that is
when Magog kills the Joker and just
irrevocably changes the entire DC
landscape I like to refer to Kingdom
Come As the DC Comics Civil War because
that's what it is it's absolutely
amazing with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching I will catch you
all later peace